let me officials a dating site but
here's the thing
it's for humans it's very selfish it
back on farmersonly.com with your own
kind let us fish have some fun for one I
think that's what they're saying is very
hard to understand I mean I'm going to
show you one of the Internet's many fish
picks and for 250 points I would like
you to give me a line from their dating
profile first up this guy who really
needs to see an orthodontist Sean I hope
this isn't too forward but I can comb
your hair with my mouth Lupe I owe you I
find a really unpleasant oral set some
help
I've got blue balls good news I'm
suppose I got guy who needs a gun
circles hey this old British lady fish
John they test makeup on fish now hi I'm
Theresa May and I approved this many
think my last three husbands were eaten
by nurse Shaw all right boy just
coincidentally is Clint I had nothing to
do I look live here next up this
surprise sponge
son you haven't seen the wire are you
crazy
I'm gonna get to it something to it the
Acting Company I know it's a triumph
Lucy I have my own contraception ha ha
ha next whoa hey it's a true boat to
fish you gay ha ha
John my friends say I have resting fish
face oh yes fine very good Tom Road
you might know me from my adult film
work I was in the film finding bin Bo
all right don't think so my tiny plastic
castle all yours
all right boys yeah we're good next up
pull up the surprised little fry how
about this
Tom I can suck the rust off the Titanic
done undefeated chubby bunny champion of
the world
yeah what do you think Lucy sometimes I
get gassy ha ha ha ha
see I always treat yeah they definitely
face parts and finally this unfortunate
puddle of fish Oh John I'm a Men's
Rights Act
[Laughter]
I can't believe that work than Los
Angeles oh I'm gonna picture that
everything